let's speak to our escena ma who's a
doctor and president of the Hong Kong
public doctors Association she's on
skype my Hong Kong thank you very much
for joining us there is clearly a
dilemma for governments here in
different opinions as to whether this is
the right time to start easing
restrictions what do you as a doctor
believe should be the indicator for
governments to decide that it's okay to
lift restrictions I think it just
depends at different between different
countries but I think first of all we
must see a very clear sign that there is
no deal custer's of new cases appear in
that country for example like Hong Kong
we have almost like 14 days 15 days with
no new local infected cases so does make
the comfort that gives the confidence
the government as well as the public to
ease some of the knockdown measures it
also depends whether the public health
care system they get well-prepared for
the second wave of disease whether they
have they have already recovered from
the first wave whether the government
have enough quarantine facilities to
quarantine those newly confirmed cases
again whether the contract raising
measures has been prepared once there is
another single cases they can trace the
content and quarantine everyone in a
very quick face so so you're saying that
you base the easing of restrictions on
the number of new cases but for what
period of time usually are are in
theoretical for any infective disease or
and he infective disease that may cause
a big public culture the best way is we
take our to incubation period of that
disease for the ankle we we mostly we
believe that the incubation period of
the disease is 14 days so the safest way
are to to observe it's 28 days if there
is no more new cases especially no more
new local confirmed cases in 28 days
from the last cases you can say it is
pretty safe
the city may have known this has been a
very lowest for and other new cases so
what about when it comes to avoiding a
second wave of infections what should
government strategy be first of all I
think I know that some countries who may
have a quite good result in the local
control they are more eager to unlock
the city but I think but as globally the
condition has not been settled while we
know that in some country like Russia or
South America they still know that the
condition has not yet peak so I think
international travel our air the flight
should still be under control and
restriction for the when I think for for
government who want to unlock the city
first of all they should have a well
plan of contact tracing a well planned
for our quarantine a quarantine
facilities or isolation for city
facilities is available once the
confirmed cases happened again because a
early contact tracing early isolation
and early quarantine is the best way to
prevent an other wave of a camel he
outbreak thank you so much for speaking
to us re cinema is the president of the
Hong Kong's doctors Association thank
you for your time